[Applaudissements]
commençons si vous ne voulez pas
un petit voyage
commençons s'il vous plaît par un petit
voyage spatio-temps on se retrouve en
17e siècle
les rues sont pavés généralement à
l'époque les codes n'étaient pas très
diffuse et la seule chose qu'on avait
c'était les mythes les légendes et les
superstitions là où on de la rue vous
rencontrez une femme vous n'arrivez pas
à lui donner d'âge
elle est très très maigre le ton pâle
voire blafar naturellement dans ces
situations là vous êtes au XVIIe siècle
vous dites que vous êtes en présence de
qui
si maintenant je rajoute un petit
élément pour vous fassiez cette
simulation imaginons que la nature
lui est mis une extrêmement grande
incisive double XL donc grande incisive
tant Blanchard très maigre d'un coup on
se retrouve avec qui
un vampire
et ça pourquoi je vous en parle parce
que peut-être que vous avez croisé cette
information la semaine dernière dans les
médias les archéologues ont découvert le
squelette d'une femme vampire ils ont
découvert le squelette une femme vampire
et les villages croyaient tellement que
c'était une vampire que enterrer ils ont
mis une lame
juste au-dessus du coup parce que dans
la croyance de l'époque on pensait que
les sorcières les vampires pouvaient
revenir à la vie et si vous voulez
en plus d'avoir finalement ce cadeau de
bienvenue c’est au cas où ça revient à
la vie avec un grand souffle elle arrive
pour la vie il y aura plus de problèmes
de migraine pour l'éternité
il y avait cette idée peut-être un peu
saugrenu pour nous qui ont peut-être de
la folie de percevoir finalement ces
gens là en disant ils ne sont pas
rationnels
et si en fait ils étaient rationnels et
si en fait ils étaient rationnels et si
en fait simplement leur postulat de
départ qui n'étaient pas je m'explique
quand vous avez vous avez un
anthropologue qui s'appelle Claudie
Strauss qui vous explique que la culture
a réponse à tout est substitue leur
droit hasard la culture a réponse à tout
est substitue leur droit
nous avons du mal avec l'imprévu nous
avons du mal avec les choses que nous
maîtrisons pas et vu que nous les
maîtrisons pas nous essayons de donner
du sens nous essayons de les contrôler
parfois être à outrance mais on essaie
de les contrôler pour plein de raisons
et ça les anthropologues notamment
j'aime susmen qui est l'un des plus
grands entre blogs anglo-saxons de
l'époque enfin notre époque actuelle
nous dit que finalement le contrôle est
apparu pour la première fois
probablement à la fin de la glaciaire
ça remonte à 12000 ans avant
l'agriculture avant qu'on passe au
Néolithique et c'est vrai c'est chouette
ce contrôle super chouette pour preuve
vous êtes tous venus ici parce qu'on
allait parler du contrôle le contrôle
permet la survie le contrôle permet la
reproduction de l'espèce le contrôle
permet même de vivre en société si vous
regardez si vous lisez
Jean-Jacques Rousseau excusez-moi si
vous lisez Jean-Jacques Rousseau il vous
explique d'un contrat social qu'on a
accepté de voir nos libertés
individuelles diminuer un petit peu
pour avoir plus de sécurité collective
et ainsi comme ça on vit dans une
société où on arrête de faire en sorte
que avec un grand H deviennent des loups
pour les autres hommes
c'est génial le contrôle le problème
c'est que c'est tellement génial c'est
tellement dans une société qui le prône
ce contrôle que parfois on va à l'excès
on va à l'excès et on tombe d'un
hypercontrôle et la société a tout fait
pour quand on a hyper control nous avons
plusieurs instances de régulation
socialisatrice dans toute notre vie qui
finalement nous donne des normes nous
donne des valeurs nous apprend à être la
personne qu'on doit être pour vivre en
société pour adopter les bons masques
sociaux au moment au bon endroit
faisons simple
commençons par la famille
avant il y avait les églises qui étaient
très importantes ensuite nous avons
l'école nous avons aux organisations
professionnelles entreprises nous avons
Patrick nous avons les partis politiques
et on pourrait même rajouter une autre
chose c'est les réseaux sociaux
sauf que un contrôle est trop fort et
quand on est trop en fonction de ce que
veulent les autres il y a de la
reproduction soyons clairs si vous êtes
là mesdames à l'heure actuelle si on a
eu la chance d'avoir des
conférencières du trop grand talent
c'est parce qu'il vous êtes affranchi un
petit peu voir beaucoup du contre-social
qui a été faite par la société c'est
parce que vous avez décidé de lâcher
prise avec ses liens qui vont retenez
qui n'avaient peut-être pas forcément
raison d'être et pas forcément de
logique
c'est ça l'idée on va même aller plus
loin quand vous pensez on a beaucoup
d'intervenants ici on parlait de l'hyper
contrôle on parlait de
on parlait de la charge mentale sauf que
peut-être que vous êtes vous avez croisé
cette information la pas longtemps
en août dernier il y a un superbe
article qui a été publié dans la revue
scientifique curane biologique cet
article nous explique quelque chose de
très important le cerveau quand il
réfléchit utilise un neurotransmetteur
activateur qui s'appelle le glutomat ce
glutomate un petites quantité est très
bénéfique pour le cerveau sauf que quand
on commence à avoir une charge mentale
importante ça fait un gros stock
et le stock est tellement important et
ça la nature qui aime super bien faite
c'est que ça vous empêche ensuite de
réfléchir avec vos votre
cortex préfrontal latéral vous ne pouvez
plus donc si le soir vous rentrez chez
vous vous pouvez plus gérer vos émotions
si le soir vous rentrez chez vous et
vous êtes plus à même de regarder les
Marseillais qui d'écouter en débat sur
Arte
c'est normal c'est votre cerveau qui
vous dit calme j'ai posé si tu continues
dans cette voie tu vas altérer mes
fonctions et ça messieurs dames ça doit
vous rappeler ça doit nous rappeler une
chose une chose importante
la principale fonction du cerveau c'est
quoi
ce n'est pas penser la principale
fonction du cerveau parfois on oublie
mais la principale fonction du cerveau
c'est de survivre et si possible même de
vivre en bonne santé pour se reproduire
donc le cerveau nous envoie des
informations si tu pousses trop et que
tu oublies que tu es encore tu oublies
que tu dois penser autrement je te fais
disjoncter et vraiment c'est on se fait
disjoncter c'est à dire que là si vous
voulez imaginer que le cortex préfrontal
c'est une passoire qui laisse passer des
choses se dit en passant les
hypersensibles ont des trous très très
grands c'est pour ça qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'informations qui arrivent parfois ils
sont submergées ils ont du mal à garder
le contrôle mais pour les autres
ces petits trous qu'on a dans le cerveau
le corps exprès frontal finalement sont
altérés et nous empêchent finalement de
vraiment purement pouvoir contrôler les
choses
je ne sais pas également si vous êtes au
courant nous avons un cerveau qui
fonctionne en mode défaut c'est à dire
que juste quelques chiffres peut-être
que vous le savez pas combien pèse un
cerveau
un cerveau pèse en moyenne un kilo 4
1 kg 4 et ça prend combien de
pourcentage consommation énergétique du
corps
entre 20 et 25%
et dites-vous que votre cerveau quand il
est en mode par un mode par défaut
concrètement si je dois simplifier les
choses consomme autant d'énergie que
quand vous penchez sur un problème de
maths compliqué
il se passe d'autres choses dans votre
cerveau c'est à le mettre par défaut
c'est pour ça que tout ce qui est yoga
tout ce qui est méditation tout ce qui
est
laissé la rêverie c'est pour ça
qu'arrive apporte autant d'informations
ce que le cerveau travaille le cerveau
sera développe des connexions neuronales
à ce moment-là
et encore une fois le but du jeu cette
survivre donc là j'ai essayé de vous
montrer déjà qu'il y a qu'à charge
mentale si on avait trop loin d'un hyper
control on avait un souci ce souci peut
être aussi corporel est-ce que parmi
vous il y en a qui ont déjà vu le film
un homme pressé avec
non
ça raconte l'histoire de réelle d'un
chef d'entreprise du CAC 40 un ancien
chef d'entreprise du CAC 40 qui
s'appelle Christian stuff
pour a-t-il président de Peugeot
président d'Airbus
grosse place et ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il était tellement dans le contrôle
tellement dans la charge mentale on se
dit en se disant qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour que mon entreprise puisse
avancer qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
qu'on puisse passer le cap du du 21e
siècle qu'il a fait un premier AVC
premier AVC une heure plus tard il était
au boulot
deuxième mavicienne semaine plus tard
troisième AVC quelques semaines plus
tard
il est arrivé au point où il ne
contrôlait plus rien notamment sa
mémoire et non seulement il s'est fait
donc licencié de Peugeot a juste titre
mais surtout la passer un an j'ai bien
dit plus d'un an avec son orthophoniste
et sa femme à tous les soif sortir et
carte de mémo qu'on utilise pour nos
enfants et c'est de reconnaître quel
était cette animal qui était blanc avec
les taches noires dessus il en est
arrivé à ça il ne pouvait plus parler et
plus faire quoi que ce soit à vouloir
être trop contre le sur contrôle il
était dans le lâcher prise total
et ça messieurs dames on le retrouve
aussi dans un autre phénomène ce
phénomène ça s'appelle la dépression
pour ceux qui ont déjà connu une
dépression
généralement
avant la dépression vous avez
l'impression d'avoir un contrôle
relativement vaste sur votre vie un jour
la dépression vous tombe sur la tête et
généralement en fonction des gens ils
vont vous dire qu'ils se retrouvent sur
une île déserte ils vont vous dire
qu'ils se retrouvent sur un radeau dans
un rade sur un radeau amer pris par le
fond ils vont vous dire qu'ils sont
enchaînés avec des murs autour et aucun
jeu espace de liberté sur la chaîne
sauf que quand vous êtes un vrai
dépression et que vous avez passé ce
stade là la deuxième étape c'est dire je
contrôle plus rien je contrôle
absolument plus rien mon corps se met à
pleurer sans que je fasse quoi que ce
soit je peux avoir le cœur qui commence
à s'accélérer impossible de ralentir je
sais pas pourquoi et surtout je ne peux
plus rien contrôler je ne peux plus
contrôler ma vie professionnelle ma vie
personnelle est compliquée en plus de ça
j'ai de la fatigue mon corps répond plus
et finalement finalement je suis seul
avec avec mon
mon lâcher prise il y a personne et en
plus de ça je ne peux même pas en parler
vous comprenez bien si je veux en parler
et gens vont me dire mais tu as tout
pour être heureux pourquoi le faire
et c'est encore plus vrai quand on est
une femme c'est encore plus vrai quand
on est en chef d'entreprise c'est encore
plus vrai qu'on est une famille
monoparentelle c'est encore plus vrai
qu'on est en sportif de haut niveau
comment du sportif de haut niveau
pourraient se plaindre alors que
finalement ils sont riches et ils ont
tout
si ce sujet la santé mentale vous
intéresse regardez ce que Kevin Love les
joueurs NBA 2m3 115 kg c'est Annie va
passer du 250 millions sur avec son
compte en banque champion champion NBA
champion du monde champion olympique et
puis si je l'ai dit il a est sorti il a
écrit une tribune très touchante dans
Player
pour revenir à la dépression
vous avez l'impression de plus rien
ressentir vous avez l'impression d'avoir
le contrôle sur rien
ou sur une chose en fait
la seule chose que vous pouvez contrôler
c'est la manière dont vous pouvez mettre
fin à ce sentiment de non contrôle
et là il y a de solution
soit vous allez jusqu'au bout et vous
avez l'impression que parce que vous
avez recommencer la partie si vous
croyez un carnation ça peut le faire
soit vous essayez de donner des petits
projets pour qu'avec un petit projet
vous puissiez reprendre un bout de
contrôle et comme ça reprendre les
choses
je termine sur un dernier point avant de
donner quelques pistes d'amélioration je
voudrais que vous compreniez qui est-ce
qu'on appelle
l'incompétence à prise quand vous a dit
que vous étiez nul à 8 ans en faisant
des maths toutes de votre vie quand vous
avez un exercice de maths vous mettez
dans une situation pour contrôler pour
pas que ça se fasse mal de ne pas le
faire et ça donne une vision aux autres
personnes que vous écoutent qui sont que
vous êtes dans un lâcher prise total
et là j'en ai beaucoup je suis formateur
je travaille beaucoup je travaille avec
des réfugiés de guerre j'ai travaillé
avec des personnes qui sont disques qui
sont nues ce qu'on appelle des Néro
atypiques avec multi 10 la première
chose pour arriver à les faire bouger
c'est mettre cette petite graine allez
regardant ou en les parlant pour montrer
tu es capable de faire tu es capable tu
peux reprendre le contrôle et faire en
sorte que ça bouge
je vois que maintenant qu'on passe sur
la dernière partie comment faire
finalement pour prendre du contrôle je
vais vous donner trois aspects
principaux la première faut développer
son anti fragilité mesdames et messieurs
l'anti fragilité c'est en néologisme qui
a été créé par Nassim Nicola Taleb et
qui a été énormément
traité par bercane qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas le garçon je vous invite
vraiment à regarder ses conférences sur
l'antifragilité elles sont fondamentales
elle nous explique la chose suivante
certaines personnes quand il y a du
quand il y a des petits stress ou des
petits changements s'écroule il y a
d'autres personnes au contraire qui
prennent le changement l'inconnu comme
des opportunités pour grandir
et on peut le développer on peut
développer ça je pense que ça passait
essentiellement par deux aspects le
premier aspect c'est beaucoup de
bienveillance si vous n'êtes pas bien
vous-même type des gens qui sont
peut-être dans ce sale en sur contrôle
si vous êtes un contrôle et que vous
avez tendance parce que si vous n'êtes
pas assez bon vous faites quelque chose
qui n'est pas
comme il faut à vous dire une grosse
merde et j'en ai vu j'ai vu des clients
qui étaient plus 14 qui avait une vie de
rêve et qui vous disent ouvertement je
suis une grosse merde j'y arrive j'ai
simplement réussi parce qu'il y avait de
la chance là votre corps se met en mode
rush c'est utile contrôle vous maîtrisez
plus rien c'est durer vous avez
l'hypothalamus hypophyse et l'exemple
surrénac qui s'active et là c'est sapin
de Noël plein de cortisol et vous
maîtrisez plus rien donc soyez
bienveillant avec vous-même lâcher prise
commence avant tout par de l'acceptation
de ce qui est et de ce qui n'est pas
ensuite prenez du temps pour vous il y a
beaucoup de gens qui à l'heure actuelle
prônent qu'il faut prendre rendez-vous
avec soi-même
mais voilà pas de connexion sociale
pendant 10 minutes et on se pose pour
essayer de retrouver son centre et de
retrouver le contrôle si vous l'avez
trop perdu si justement est en sur
contrôle parce que je maintiens le sur
contrôle n'est pas du contrôle du
contrôle est l'illusion que vous
contrôlez mais vous comprenez rien du
tout en fait
la dernière chose c'est aller dans un
processus d'individuation comme disait
le psychanalyste car young cherchez
votre authenticité recherchez votre
intensifier votre authenticité qu’est-ce
qui vous motive qu'est-ce qui motive ou
qu'est-ce qui ferait plaisir à l'enfant
intérieur qui se cache en vous parce que
finalement à force de mettre des masques
pour nous pour aller avec tel groupe
sociaux tes groupes parfois on en oublie
qui on est c'est souvent ce qu'on voit
avec des enfants sur Instagram avec des
adolescentes à vouloir trop vous montrer
à vouloir trop qu'on a trouvé son image
ok mais finalement elle se perdent donc
en faisant ça ça vous permettra petit à
petit de lâcher prise parce que vous
saurez plus facilement faire la
différence entre ce qui vous appartient
ce qui vous appartient pas
le dernier point que je voulais voir
avec vous c'est les émotions nous sommes
un monde depuis au moins Descartes où on
nous dit les émotions c'est dangereuse
il faut s'en protéger on s'en protège
tellement qu'on s'en coupe
sauf que comment vous faites pour
absorber le futur pour absorber
l'inconnu si vous coupez des choses si
vous avez des puissances en vous qui
sont finalement des signaux et des
moteurs pour comprendre le monde et pour
avancer
c'est pas possible ou alors si vous le
faites dites moi comment et c'est je
pense en faisant tout ça qu'on arrivera
à mieux comprendre ce que disait Mac
orne le grand aventurier sud-africain si
vous attendez 100% des réponses pour
vous mettre en route vous ne partez
jamais ce qu'il faut savoir 5% mais bien
contrôler ces 5% notamment les billets
et autres pour après tes 95 autres pour
cent des réponses arrivent par la suite
au final mesdames et messieurs
n'oublions pas que nous sommes pas
simplement les héritiers des
cultivateurs des cultivateurs
qui eux contrôlaient nous sommes
également les
chasseurs-cueilleurs qui eux étaient
dans le lâcher prise et allons même plus
loin ça n'a Hassan
a expliqué une chose très vraie là on
est en train de parler de plein de
choses sur le contrôle sur le lâcher
prise mais parce que nous sommes des
privilégiés si un moment donné vous
savez pas qu'est-ce que vous avez donné
à bouffer à vos gosses le soir si un
moment donné vous avez peur d'entrer
chez vous parce que vous allez vous
prendre des coups parce que vous avez
peur de passer de faire des enfants
parce qu'on sait pas si attire va pas
exploser dans quelques années
il y aura pas de il y aura pas de lâcher
prise il y aura pas de contrôle vous
avez simplement subir donc c'est pour ça
en ayant je pense sincèrement que si on
essaie de mettre ces choses en place
pour aller mieux à titre individuel ça
peut nous permettre à titre collectif
voir la puissance et d'avoir
la performance nécessaire pour pouvoir
répondre aux défis qui s'offrent à nous
savoir des défis économiques des défis
sociaux et des défis climatiques je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]